I used to think whining was a little
known form of prayer I've been the guy
stop my I don't I want my stuff I
deserve in you you ever had a good whine
party I didn't say whne I said whine
have you ever done that I've done that
but something about the pain of going
through losing everything was Shar and I
and something about us saying never
again and I don't ever want to be here
again something about doing that that
grows you up doesn't it and it makes you
a full grown woman it makes you a full
grown man an adult adults devise a plan
and follow it children do what feels
good does that mean adults never do
anything impulsive no it just means we
plan our
impulses